Speaker 1: Other news, Biden has been giving
a lot of press conferences lately.
Joe Biden actually called out Donald Trump,
he used the phrase, my predecessor, but Joe
Biden called out Donald Trump on the insane
level of adding and adding to the debt that
Donald Trump did.
And it's only insane because of an interview
that I'm going to read a snippet from from
from March of 2016 where Donald Trump claimed
he was going to pay off the entire 19 trillion
dollar national debt inside of eight years.
And instead, what Donald Trump did was added
about eight trillion dollars to the debt rather
than pay off 19 trillion reading from this
article.
Biden slams Trump for racking up eight trillion
dollars in debt as he vows Democrats will
pay for their spending plan by taxing the
rich.
Now, listen, a lot of people get caught up
in this debt deficit and they treat the United
States economy as though it's a household
budgeting situation, that debt is bad and
you must have a balanced budget because that's
what you do with your checkbook.
There isn't an analog with the way a government
runs.
There isn't a correlation between the two
because it's completely different.
You don't print money in your personal household.
The United States government has that power
now save the risks of inflation.
It's manageable reading from this article,
after months of negotiations, the Senate passed
President Joe Biden's one trillion dollar
infrastructure bill on Tuesday.
A day later, the president made sure Americans
knew his economic agenda would represent a
sharp break from President Trump.
Quote, This isn't going to be anything like
my predecessor, whose unpaid tax cuts and
other spending added nearly eight trillion
dollars in his four years to the national
debt, eight trillion, Biden said on Wednesday.
Here, in more full context are those remarks
from Joe Biden.
Speaker 3: And they're going to be fully paid
for.
This isn't going to be anything like my predecessor,
whose unpaid tax cuts and other spending added
nearly eight trillion dollars in his four
years to the national debt, eight trillion
dollars, they didn't even report to try to
pay for their tax cuts, which went straight
to largest corporations and the wealthiest
Americans.
The investments I'm proposing will be fully
paid for over the long term by having the
largest corporations, including the 55 corporations
that paid zero federal tax last year and the
super wealthy began to pay their fair share.
They'll still make a lot of money but pay
their fair share.
That means actually reduce the national debt,
improve our fiscal position over the long
run.
My build back better agenda is fiscally responsible,
the fiscally responsible way to reduce the
cost for families.
In fact, you're hearing economists across
the board confirm this,
Speaker 1: and, you know, as a matter of follow
up, Joe Biden has promised that he's not going
to raise taxes on anyone making less than
four hundred thousand dollars a year.
So if you're out there and you make four hundred
and one thousand dollars per year, good for
you and your taxes are likely going to go
up.
And that is OK.
You have benefited greatly from the opportunity
and the system that was set up to provide
you the the opportunities to make that kind
of money for the rest of you, which is the
vast majority of you watching your taxes aren't
going to go up.
Even today, during the same press conference,
Joe Biden reiterated that he's not even going
to raise the gas tax.
That's not something that's going to happen.
So the article continues, the passage of the
infrastructure plan through the Senate was
a major achievement for Biden's build back
better agenda.
And during his remarks, he touted the plans
for creating jobs and boosting economic growth.
Among other things, he also used this achievement
to criticize the debt that came from Trump's
tax cuts, saying that Trump didn't even attempt
to pay for them, which is a fact.
Even when things were good prior to the coronavirus
coming on the scene, Donald Trump was racking
up a trillion and a trillion and a half dollars
worth of debt every single year.
So all these Republicans out there, the Mike
Lees of the world and the Ted Cruz's of the
world can zip it.
They can pipe down about their concern about
saddling our children with debt.
Now, they could stop it because you didn't
say anything.
Then you passed overwhelmingly passed a tax
relief bill for millionaires and billionaires.
With no regard for how it was going to be
paid for, how the hole that was left in the
government coffers was going to be made up.
You just saddle another eight trillion dollars
onto our precious children.
You scream Chicken Little, according to the
Federal Reserve data, the national debt rose
by almost seven point eight trillion dollars
during Trump's time in office.
During that time, Republicans approved a major
corporate tax cut and added two trillion dollars
to the national debt, a measure many Democrats
and economists said favored the wealthiest
Americans.
They said that because that is the truth.
Now, this is what's interesting.
In March of twenty sixteen, Donald Trump sat
down with Bob Woodward of of Watergate fame,
who still works for The Washington Post, and
he gave an interview in which this particular
segment took place.
This interaction took place about the national
debt and what Donald Trump's plans were to
combat the national debt and continued deficits
and indeed how he planned to maybe pay down
the national debt.
Donald Trump says we've got to get rid of
the 19 trillion in debt.
Obviously, I'm reading it in my voice because
Donald Trump doesn't sound like me, nor does
he.
He's not as coherent.
Bob Woodward replied, How long would that
take?
I think I could do it fairly quickly because
of the fact that the numbers.
And then Woodward interjects, he says, what's
fairly quickly Trump?
Well, I would say over a period of eight years
and I'll tell you why.
Woodward, would you ever be open to tax increases
as a part of that to solve the problem? Trump
I don't think I'll need to.
The power is trade.
Our deals are so bad.
WOODWARD That would be two trillion dollars
a year, meaning he would be paying off two
trillion dollars of national debt every year.
But in order to do that, you'd need to not
have deficits.
Donald Trump, certainly deficits of one and
one and a half and two trillion dollars aren't
going to allow you to be in a position to
pay off two trillion dollars in debt.
Trump says no, but I'm renegotiating all of
our deals, Bob.
The big trade deals that we're doing so badly
on with China, 505 billion this year in trade.
We're losing with everybody.
And Republicans hate this hook, line and sinker.
They fell for it, bamboozled by a con man,
by a carnival barker, by a grifter, by a charlatan.
Donald Trump did not pay off a single dollar
in debt, as I've already referenced, he added
seven point eight thousand billion dollars.
To the national debt, great, great job, Republicans,
and now that we're trying to spend some money
for infrastructure, we're trying to spend
some money on stimulus to keep people from
losing their homes, from to keep people from
being homeless.
To keep people who are unemployed afloat,
then they want to ask about
how are we going to pay for lost?
It's hypocrisy at its finest.